hey everyone it's Mike Balto's and this
is part two of the order flows market
analysis for September 7 2017 the talk
about the second half of the session you
got a nice rally in the ESPYs
even though we closed a little bit lower
for the day you know we did have a nice
late rally off the lows gold gold
continues to keep moving up we're up
another 1% one point one percent today
oil is around 29 bucks as this hurricane
Irma starts taking aim at Florida and
the Gulf as well and the Euro euros back
over 120 we traded I think up to 120 21
there was no action from the ECB and we
know which is keeping the stimulus in
place so that said let's just jump into
things again you know the disclaimer
this presentation is for educational and
informational purposes only and should
not be considered a solicitation to buy
or sell a futures contract or make any
other type of investment decision
futures trade contain substantial risk
and it's not for every investor an
investor could potentially lose all or
more than the initial investment risk
capital is money that could be lost
without jeopardizing one's financial
security or lifestyle only risk capital
should be used for training and only
those with sufficient risk capital
should consider trading past performance
it's not necessarily indicative of
future results again same tools as
always the order flows trader volume
footprint chart the Delta scalper which
is an order flow tool and I do lately
I've been talking a bit more about the
price rejector I'll probably talk about
that again today you know these are
Delta scalper and price rejector are two
additional tools in order flow
additional indicators outside of the
order flows trader they sell separately
they do work on normal bar charts in
case you know you're not really up to
speed yet on trading with an order flow
so let's just sort of pick up where we
left off okay so this is crude crude
right now so what time is it now it's
1:00 in the morning Chicago time crude
not doing much very tight range in the
evening session again we're trading
49:12 here but you know what I can't
remember what time I did that recording
was Ronnie 11 I think but anyway you
know we had this little sell off from
the I remember talking about this in the
morning session so you had that sell-off
you get down here at 10:50 for this move
actually was very quick 1054
are you you sold off about 30 cents you
hit this area here you got some small
Delta's 37:14 you seen some buying
coming in you got the up bars this bar
opponent control right on the towards
the bottom starts rallying up here kind
of goes sideways and again we're just
hanging around this yellow line which is
the unchanged price level 49 bucks now
you remember earlier I was talking about
if you remember we did rally up off the
lows we came right up here where he had
the price rejecter and he sold off you
know on days we're really lacking
direction you tend to rotate around
opening price that doesn't mean you're
gonna be training you know 49:14 for two
hours no you're gonna go above you're
gonna go below like you're doing here
right you above you get down below you
got a indication to sell up here or buy
down here
you know just in here some small Delta's
you know trade is evenly matched
you know buyers and sellers are evenly
matched that's what the small deltas are
telling you you know and when buyer's or
seller's are match you know we have
delta of fourteen it tells you you know
net aggressive mine was fourteen so that
tells you the volume was twenty four
eighty-six but buying and selling was
was pretty even so we sold off okay we
sold off again you know down to one
o'clock this area and nothing really
major you come down here again you know
every time you sorta dip below this area
you get you know
buyers and sellers evenly matched again
you see it down here you got some small
Delta's 1892 honestly you know you're
coming down here you see you got you
know strong sellers right look at these
deltas 700 700 700 a bunch of imbalances
so you know there's net aggressive
selling here okay
no but then what happens is you just
start going sideways you get this one
bar nice positive delta so buyers are
stepping up and you came in here so you
had sellers net aggressive sellers you
know think about this for a second you
got market going down I'm talking with
my hands you can't see me I'm talking
with my hands I'm pointing down you know
you have this market coming down a good
net aggressive sellers very strong 700
700 700 in the Delta that's how you know
it's in that aggressive sellers and it's
quite strong by the number you got these
imbalances 135 80 89 160 191 157 you get
down here and get down to below 49 bucks
what happens now you got a
my income and net aggressive mind so
above at this time you know above forty
nine bucks you got net aggressive
selling you get below forty nine bucks
you got net aggressive buying and then
what happens you start trading right
around forty nine bucks over our next
few bars here next two bars and you got
small Delta's your trading 3,900 your
trading 5,000 so you know this is about
nine thousand contracts if you add up
the volume of these two bars and your
delta is basically minus one hundred and
what is that hundred and seventy okay
minus 80 here or bars raise three
thousand nine hundred minus 92 on a bar
you trade five thousand you know those
are small Delta's so it's telling you
these sellers are meeting buyers down
here okay they're trading they're happy
to trade at this price level you know so
it's sort of found this new area to
trade that you know that's that's what
the market is telling you in the order
flow you get down here and you have the
buyers the buyers are stepping up then
here you got the Delta scalper kicking
in is telling you hey you know what net
aggressive buyers are taking over
you're really rally not really you sort
of rally back up towards this opening
price 49:14 you end up closing the day
up in here around 49 21 I'll say 20 you
got down to it was the closing price
forty nine ten it's just here you know
after he got the Delta scalper telling
you buyers came in yeah in the evening
session you did pop up but right now you
know very tight range 26 down to oh was
that oh seven so basically a nineteen
sticker Ange in the evening session so
kind of quiet right now in the evening
session coming into Friday I didn't talk
about the tenor range in minis I'd
honestly I didn't look at them that much
today I know I know I spent some time
looking at the at the five range but
yeah and anything you know really major
takeaway no the same thing that you saw
in the in the morning you really just
sort of hanging around you know the
opening price right here twenty four
sixty three and a quarter most of this
most of the session even you do sell off
make a new low here around 11:00
something eleven forty and you start
reality what do you rally back up you
rally back up to the sixty three and a
quarter in the immune session
you know we did pop up before Asia open
but we did sell off and we're just right
on her lows here about 130 right now so
again I'm curious you know we're coming
into the European session the European
cash open in about 30 minutes I'd be
curious to see if we get a bounce up you
know if this is this low is gonna hold
it's not a ratio you do have a
divergence so but right now you got one
divergence another divergence although
this is at 8:45 this next one is at 1:30
that's a long time that's the problem
I say problem that's one of the things
you gotta keep in context and when
you're trading the Asian Justin
sometimes it's boring as watching paint
dry
you know from 8:45 to 11:45 this is it
in one bar that's how that's how quiet
it is and nothing you know too excited
in here I said you the for range looks
better than this
then this 10 range I mean yeah you do
have a ratio here price rejector giving
you this buy right on the cell which is
also nice but again not much of a move
up you know you're only talking to move
about 2 or 3 points that's about it kind
of a quiet quiet afternoon quiet you
know after 12 I got I want to show you
that I was debating whether I should
even make this video you know because
then people say oh you know he didn't
make a video because order flow sucked
in the afternoon and you would have lost
all your money but now you know it's I'm
making it anyway um it was interesting
thing here on the low that you don't see
on the 10 range chart because on the 4
range it's split over two bars here at
11:36 1137 I touched on this I talked
about this earlier on the previous video
and I can't I always like it when you
get less volume the second time you're
coming into a low and you're 36 15 yeah
technically it's less I mean there's
just you know I'm talking what is that
19 contracts less but still it's it's
less I do I do like that when you hit
the low test a higher test a low again
you got less volume it's too mean it's
always a nice sign that prices or you
know in this case sellers are not as
interested in selling into the lows you
know even here 939 versus 361 mm here
only 515 so the second time you're
coming down
can time you're coming down into this
low where are your aggressive sellers
that you had earlier
you know it's you're seeing less you
know two thousand against five hundred
you know that's this is one-fourth less
nine thirty nine against 369 this is a
third less and thirty six against
fifteen that's you know that's half less
so there's less there's less interest in
selling into the slow and what do you do
you got a price rejecter again giving
you the buy that you saw in the ten
range as well you get a little bit move
up here you get the price Delta scalper
coming in giving you a sell but it you
know point control holds here that's
this line here rallies back up you know
gets back up that opening price so
realistically out of this trade you know
if you can get you know up two points
that would be great but again you know
my target optimistic target is just
sixty three and a quarter so you know
assuming you're getting along in here
somewhere around I don't know sixty and
a half sixty and three-quarters you know
to get out at at sixty now above sixty
three is is great but again you know on
days where there's it's kind of
directionless you're gonna hang around
the opening price here you get the
goodnesses just before two o'clock you
get the stack selling imbalance what do
you get right afterwards you get a
bullish ratio
all right here seventy six and you know
that's not a good sign you got a nice
bearish sign here and then you got a
bullish sign that's that's not what you
want you want a bearish sign to follow
your initial bearish sign then you just
sort of hang around in here one bar two
bars three bars four bars by this point
here you're looking at this bearish
ratio 170 point three and you're
thinking hey we should start selling off
what happens is you go Ali right back up
into the area of the stacked imbalance
so it's it's four levels you're sorry
you know four bars after this initial
imbalance and you're just trading back
in there at this point it's really
losing its effectiveness now I'm not
gonna say oh yeah you see it sold off no
by this point I'm looking to get out
especially when it pokes up you know it
starts trading above it you know here
you had only traded nine but you know at
that time you know you gotta realize
what's happening you see this market
start poking higher trading you know
sixty four sixty four and a corridor
sixty four and a half
kaberi Asik can very well have easily
got higher but it could have gone higher
in this case it didn't it sold off again
but you know really you're expecting
this trade to happen you're the move to
happen sooner but the first sign that
it's not gonna really work out is this
I'm not looking as this is a level you
know to hold all day long I know some
people like to I don't to me this is a
sign aggressive selling is coming in and
you know 30 minutes later that
aggressive selling the whole point of it
said you rally back up here in here you
know 10 minutes later I want to see more
aggressive sign okay you got a couple of
imbalances but then you rally back up in
there you know at this point you know
where is it aggressive selling is not
strong enough and the only the other
thing to take away is you're trading
right around your opening price and
again going back to what I said you know
when it's a directionless market quite a
quiet market you tend to hang around the
opening price so you know the fact that
it's happening right above the opening
price and you can't really sell off it's
just telling me this markets
directionless again you know I'm not
gonna say yeah I see it sold off here
you'd cover down here at 61 and a half
know by this point I'd be looking to get
out of the trade already but you know
this fourth bar that's what I'm looking
to get out I'm not looking for it you
know it could be trading a stacked
imbalance at 155 and and you know to you
know three o'clock I'm still in this
trade and it's just going sideways on me
so you got this Delta scalper giving you
this buy here at 239 you get a nice
little move up here this bar I found
could be quite bearish unfortunately
like this stacked imbalance it's
happening just on the other side of the
opening price there's a lot yellow
orange line I suppose it says orange
would actually it looks yellow on my
screen I find this bar very bearish and
looking for the market is sell-off it
doesn't it gets back down to the opening
price again you know you that's why you
see all these you know you can't all
have these signals right or and you're
just hanging around you know this the
opening price when you understand that
you know opening prices is a magnet for
you know directionless days then you
you'll it makes it a lot easier to
understand why you know you're not
getting many moves here like this is a
bullish sign you
at rally a little bit this is a bearish
bar does it sell off yeah it sells off
back to the opening price and then here
lease now you're getting you know some
multiple imbalances got one two three
now you're coming into the cash close
though three o'clock right here that's
why you got this heavy volume in here
five thousand that's selling a balance
to come right back with a nice buying a
balance of 2,400 you know when you're
trading in a tight range all right
you're not gonna I don't know I prefer
to break out of the range and take the
trades in the direction as you're moving
outside rather than try and fade it and
then move back in you know like this
trade here to here you know back here up
to there back down I'm really looking
for the move away from you know your
your value area so to speak you're not
on the volume profile you know this is
what it looked like here you notice how
quiet that they was 59 and a half to 68
and three-quarter so not even ten points
yeah you're a port of control is just
down here sixty-two but again you know
it's hard to get excited when you're
trading inside of your value Airy I'd
much rather see us start rallying above
sixty six sixty six and a half for a
breakout you know you're not getting it
right now in the evening session so you
know any moves that you can get you know
on one of these narrow range days in
these days with not much going on again
it's it's it's easy to get excited on a
trade that you know when you're breaking
out possibly you know
on the upside rather than try to fade it
back in you know you guys two different
types of trading right there's trend
traders there's non trend traders decide
what you are or you don't have to choose
one or the other I mean you could use
both strategies right that's all you
should have more than one trading
strategy in your trading you know
because if you're just trading it's all
a trend
breakout strategy but on a day like
today you're not gonna get much and
you're gonna get chopped up and you know
if you have a trend fading strategy only
you know on trend is you're gonna get
chopped up as well so you know it's good
to have both and you know hopefully you
know you could make make money with the
two of them together preferably should
have more but everyone should have sort
of a I want to call it like a playbook
of you know types of trades it to
looking for in different market
conditions um but anyway yeah just
really quick in the evening session yeah
up this low you got a divergence no
ratio down in here you got the
divergence you got the ratio afterwards
this is 122 we'll see if it's gonna
rally you got Delta scalper as well
he'll be nice if we get a rally but
again it's it's kind of quiet it's
coming into Friday morning right now in
Europe maybe wants to you know after 2
o'clock the market can start to put in
the move was the other the other two
markets I looked at or five years and
bonds but just really quick you know
this is the three in a row ratio ratio
ratio the red bar the pullback it's now
it's split into two sessions this is the
evening session right now this is the
close right here so you got the pullback
you got the pullback between the two
pointed controls then you got to move
higher you know up to this high at 31
and a half eventually you did make you
know new highs after that here starting
to come off a little bit off this high
but the important thing was again you
know again it's one of these things you
know de are you gonna trade it through
two sessions you know probably not by
this time by four o'clock in the
afternoon you know people are tired of
trading ready for the day but again you
can see how it works right one ratio two
ratios three ratios the pullback in
between you know the red bar you have to
pull back between the two pointed
controls of the second and third bar in
here you can see it pulls back down in
here and then it makes the move back up
you know that's that's the three in the
Rope three in a row I can you know just
sort of follow up from earlier we had
made that high earlier you got the price
rejector up here right on the high we
sell-off come down into this area short
of trade deltas minus a thousand plus
1000-2000 plus two thousand you know
before you get that rally going on up in
here you know and another way for me
another way I determine if a market is
going sideways is this red bar green bar
red bar and green bar you know one is
alternating in the just in the the bars
are colors to me that's
and also a sign of a market trying to
make up its mind and then you got
bearish ratio you don't have a bullish
ratio being a bearish ratio then bullish
ratio it's not they start moving away
that you know it come it becomes more
clearer here but you know oftentimes you
see bearish ratio then bullish ratio
then bearish ratio then bullish ratio
that's also a sign of a market going
sideways bonds not much really to get
too excited about I mean price rejecter
again so earlier you know today was a
nice day for the price rejecter in the
bonds so you had your high here and your
Delta negative Delta on the high
remember I was talking about that it
came off started coming off nicely here
negative Delta negative Delta negative
Delta then the strong negative Delta
here - 1300 keeps going down down down
you get down to this low area you got
you know this bar here you know I
thought maybe we get a little bit of a
bounce we did and it came right back up
and we got bounced about two ticks and
then came up with a bearish ratio
negative Delta uh negative Delta in the
bar but selling a balance selling a
balance next bar another ratio selling
imbalance you ended up with positive
Delta a small one you know yet this
buying in here at this o at this 10
level right here
aggressive buying mm so yeah it's um you
know you're aggressive sellers in there
still then he came down in here this is
the price rejector giving you this buy
here you know it's it's one of those
things it's you know without this price
trajectory you probably wouldn't notice
that this is gonna be a low because you
see all you still got negative Delta
this here is this is the you turn this
black arrow and you know price rejecter
black arrow
you know it's telling me you know
possibly just can be a low and we start
working our way up here then you get
some selling you know then it looks it's
just kind of going sideways unfortunate
it's not a clear move just one of those
winding moves again is this is 1218 you
know this is 2 o'clock here okay it's
nice to look back at the close here at 4
o'clock and say oh yeah it was a
terrific move but it wasn't it was this
was a very slow period in here the
markets not really doing
after the cash closed you did get the
rally obviously in the evening session
we are trading higher right now you know
this is the Delta scalper given the cell
right here you get up to your high you
got the divergence you got the negative
Delta next bar Delta scalper giving you
a sell and you know we're trading about
you know a few ticks lower right now but
again you know this even though there
was a signal in here you know for most
people it's gonna be hard to pick up on
the order flow honestly you know this I
said you know that's why I've programmed
these these indicators you know the
bottles is suite of indicators and then
the price rejecter because it will help
me pick up the stuff which you know
sometimes you know on slow days quiet
days it's easy to you know start surfing
the internet or you know open up
Facebook on your phone and stuff and if
you're not really tuned into the market
you're gonna miss things like that
that's why we I have these ideas or not
ideas you know but these ways I trade
you know coded into these things I'm not
trying to change it you know it's sort
of to say not change it really what the
reason why I have these things coded is
to help me you know it's a tool say hey
idiot put down your phone start looking
at this market you're getting some
science in here of life of the market
possibly starting to rally okay I can
take a look yeah I see hey you know you
got this is interesting you know this
bar you've got you got the negative
Delta so you got some support of buying
in here it's not that great honestly
1067 1061 but earlier you had two
thousand in here and i know that there's
some buying going on in here because you
got that imbalance on this on the
previous bar so you know maybe the yeah
you could see that there is buying
coming in at this at this area down in
here i said they get its it's not
something that's easy to pick up
you know honestly it's one of the
problems that i said i deal with a lot
of people on order flow and one of the
problems that people have is they try to
put everything together at once and
oftentimes they don't understand
everything to put together and so
they're sort of you know they got all
the pieces to the puzzle
but you know they're putting in the
wrong pieces they're trying to attach
the wrong pieces together you know like
those are those puzzles you know yeah
you have the pieces to the puzzle but
when you're putting it together you got
to put the right piece with the right
piece at the right time you know if you
try to put the wrong piece with you know
a wrong piece and it's it's not gonna
work right so anyway you know we did get
this nice little rally up off that okay
what else it's really quick this is a
hundred ticky mini Dow chart you know
this is the Balto's transition and you
see how it's supposed to pick up the
market transitioning from supply to
demand or demand to supply you know it
just didn't find it slow here give sort
of a false signal stopped out here got a
little move here made the low this was a
nice high area this is a nice low area
yeah another one here another one down
in here another couple down in there
again it's it's more let me see what
else I got a chart I could find it here
I forgot which one I was looking at it
earlier Gold I think it was you know
gold had some been having some nice
moves
this year honestly and this is a
one-minute chart this is Delta scalper
this is the evening session right now
you know you get some nice little moves
again you know if you're pure I hate to
say you know if you're a short-term
trader you know in you know people
companies say hey I don't have much time
to trade you know maybe I got a couple
hours a day
okay well try and find those hours try
and find a market that you know it's got
decent liquidity during the hours you
can trade and stick to those hours right
say say you you know some people say I
work a nine-to-five okay why you wake up
two hours earlier and watch the buns or
something you know or watch the e-mini
z' in the morning before you go to work
or something like that you know find
something to watch but stick to that
time and you know be consistent on it
don't sit yeah okay I'll watch the buns
today then I'll watch the knee guy
tomorrow and the next day I'm looking at
the euro currency
you're gonna it's nice if you could look
at the same thing every day and
understand you know what you're looking
at then you could expand into some other
markets but you know the gold more than
gold get some decent moves here this was
when the number came out I mean look at
that move the dr. scalper gave you the
buy right before the big pop up is a
1-minute chart so does a decent move
there again the straight here failed get
a little bit of a move here a little bit
of a move here this one fails this one
fails get a little move no failed a
little move here that one fails nothing
spectacular but it's still some decent
moves to be had I mean if you're only
getting you know a bunch of trades that
you're getting stopped out at small
losses but then you get you know like
here alright let's just you know look at
that right you're getting I got the
right thing across her no it's not
working
but you know say you're getting short
here at 13 you know 4980 but your stops
up here at 1350 30 you know that's 50
cents but you know if you're getting
along here at you know 49 and you're
covering it at 50 you know you're making
a buck
alright you know risk to reward you know
you're getting short you know in here at
you know 50 120 you know you get a
little bit of move down here but over
out that is 50 70 50 80 again here you
get a nice a little move there but you
get a quick stop out I mean it's fine
taking taking the losses again I don't
know if you'd be holding this through
the number honestly you know any of
these all these employment numbers right
today you had the the weekly jobless
claims you know you got a hurricane
alright they're just affected Texas and
Louisiana to a smaller extent now you
got hurricane Irma which is gonna be hit
in Florida this weekend or maybe sooner
I don't I'm not tracking it but watch
these weekly jobless numbers I think
there's gonna be pretty volatile these
numbers coming out over the next the
next couple weeks and you know keep that
in mind so
you know trade it honestly trade it
cautiously but um you know just the you
know just be aware of that you know you
could see some volatility in the jobs
numbers last thing people are really
concerned about is their job when you
know the house is flooding so this is
this is the gold uni Renko chart here
you can see that here and this is the
Delta scalper so nice little move here
you know not much here this buy started
work out and failed yeah little by here
later here you got a nice sell then you
got a nice by later in the day so you
know it's a move from you know 50 and a
half up to you know 53 and a half just
like this is from 51 and a half down
into here at you know 49 49 and a half
so even though you're you getting you
know half a dollar
stop outs but if you're getting moves
that are you know 2 or 3 bucks or bucks
and you know you're risking 0.5 to get
back for you know that's that's what
having a good risk to reward ratio is is
all about and you know this really quick
look you know this is the the uni Renko
what is this mini Dow again you know
some terrific moves here see here you
know getting along at you know 70 you
know it's called 80 it's gonna be quick
you know it's up here to your cell at 83
sorry at 8:30 you know so that's the 50
cent move 50 point move and then back
down again another 50 points that's how
quick it's a hundred points right there
in the in the Dow so you know for for
people like here say oh I got long here
right I got I got long at whoops oh my
crosshairs isn't working properly though
I got long here at 8:10 but I got
stopped out at you know 800 so I didn't
take this next trade so I just had a
loss well you don't take this next trade
it's again from you know 8:05 all the
way up to 840 and then you know people I
still get messages yeah I got I got long
at 8:05 and then I got stopped out at
breakeven down here oh why why are you
getting stopped out at breakeven here
you learn to manage your trade
to trail your stop and get out you know
while the gettin's good you know you're
50/50 you know 40 ticks went into this
trade as a winner you know even if you
give back 20 and get out at 8:20 you're
still ahead you know you're still
getting four you're risking you know 10
ticks to get back you know 20 25 ticks
you know here you're getting in some
nice moves here even in the evening
session you got a nice little move there
and starting a little move here you know
these moves here didn't work out late in
the session it would have been nice to
say hey there was a nice buy signal down
here on this low but there wasn't not
gonna make it up anyway I think that's
about it I could show you a Nasdaq chart
really quick again Union Rinku chart
maybe reason why I'm showing this cuz
you know people have been messing it can
I use it with the Union Renko chart yeah
of course you can you can some cells
some decent cells here here we'll buy
here the sell failed this cell here
failed fine you know yeah nice little
buy there a little bit of a move here
before I went back up this one failed a
little bit of a move there this one yeah
we're stuck you out I think yeah this is
free cash in here this is right after
the cash got a little move up came down
and then made the move these are the
moves I hate you know work shorted it
starts moving up kicks down and then
makes the move you know but that's
that's trading you know that's how those
things go but anyway um you know and
this so well in this video for now and
you know see how things come shape up on
Friday so have a have a great Friday and
a great weekend if I don't hear from me
bye bye oh wait forgot you know if you
want to learn more about order flow go
to my website order flows I wanna learn
more about deltas scalpel go to Delta
scalper if you really want if you want
to be alerted to any new videos I put
out subscribe to the YouTube channel
click the
little red button below that or to the
side down here it says subscribe and you
know I try to get videos out on a fairly
regular basis it's time permitting and I
don't see these you know market
permitting but mostly time permitting
there's always something in some market
talk about you know if I try to talk
about the same markets every day I'm not
trying to pull stuff up saying oh you
only show you the great-looking charts I
pretty much stick to bonds fives
Minnie's euro currency you know the
major contracts the main Contras I do
talk about some of the smaller ones once
in a while but again you know I try to
be consistent in the markets there's no
point you know saying it only showing
you the perfect charts of the day you
know because you're not gonna really
learn you know part of learning is going
through you know bad market conditions
you know as far as I see yes I've been
trading for you know I've been involved
in trading since 1994 I was on the
trading floor on the CME and I really
I've traded through every can't say
every possible but a lot of different
conditions obviously you know the
Russian crisis the Asian financial
crisis SARS you know the lt-col analysis
I can't remember it now long-term
capital management LTC him you know that
big debacle that went on and really
affected the market nick leeson you know
people never you know before the Asian
financial crisis nobody knew about Hang
Seng you know outside of Asia and then
you know they after financial crisis
Asia financial crisis back in the 90s
happened
everyone would be calling and trading I
say what's the Hang Seng doing what's
the Hang Seng doin it was funny he said
joke you know like last week you guys
never cared now everyone cares about it
you know obviously you know I've been
through other tsunamis in Japan you know
trading that you know 9/11 was a big
thing you know I've seen a lot of
different market conditions I'm not
saying I saw every market condition you
know I sort of wish I was born a little
bit earlier but then I'd be much older
now but I would have been like to trade
these markets back in the 70s actually
you know during the great grain embargo
with where Russia was pulling a fast one
on the US
you know I had you know if I could go
back in time I'd sort of pick out the
times when I wish I was trading again
you know back you know in like in the
70s there's some great great times to be
trading but anyway guys you know I'm
just talking nonsense have a look have a
great day and catch you guys later bye
bye